la gare de la grande chaîne
mise en service en 1886 le port de la
pointe des galets et reliés aux
principales régions productrices de
sucre par an chemin de fer inauguré le
11 février 1882
de nombreuses haltes et pas moins de
treize gare rythme le parcours celle de
la grande chaloupe est un noeud
ferroviaire stratégique c'est en effet
ici que se croiser les convois venant du
nord et du sud
des 126 km de voies ferrées installé
entre saint benoît saint pierre ne
subsiste aujourd'hui que quelques
tronçons dont celui situé aux abords de
la grande chaloupe
autres vestiges de l'histoire du chemin
de fer réunionnais la locomotive à
vapeur schneider et la gare de la grande
chaloupe
l'édifice comporte à l'origine de salle
la plus petite fée à la fois office de
bureau et de salle datant la seconde
sert de logement à l'employé du chemin
de fer
une cour permet aux voyageurs de prendre
le frais après une traversée éprouvante
du tunnel envahi par la fumée de la
locomotive à vapeur
programmée dès la départementalisation
en 1946 la disparition du chemin de fer
devient effective en 1963 après la
livraison de la première route du
littoral sa mise en deux fois deux voies
en 1976 mettra définitivement un terme à
cette épopée de près d'un siècle
d - architectural de l' aventure du
train à la réunion la gare de la grande
chaloupe est devenu monument historique
en 1998